all right this should be a fun one I
think this was the most interesting
addition in our list it certainly had
the most overall sort of backing in the
office I feel number two and our top 25
games of the year it's rocket Li in fact
there's been rules in place because we
play it so much that we're starting to
get in trouble people have been saying
there's there's not that much problems
in the office with people playing a game
since counter-strike it's a game that's
fun to play with people you know like
lots of games are and it's also great
thing to play on your own with randoms
which is which is pretty impressive
considering it's again Murray you really
have to work as a team and because of
the chat system you're not really going
out of your way it is maybe say horrible
things you're just enjoying the vibe of
everyone online you're all kind of
working together as a team to get better
as somebody who plays a lot of soccer
football games like FIFO and pro AB to
me this is actually filled that gap
because it it's a game that feels
actually more like when I go out onto a
pitch and play a game of football then
any game will say before and that's
because you're kind of the foot in this
game you're not just controlling it like
a person and telling them what to do
you're controlling where that ball gets
hit and you're trying to place it
somewhere I'm not that's almost like
entirely unique in video games there is
really this tangible effect that you can
see your practice manifests in when
you're playing you know I play at home
but I'm still the weak link in the
office but that's just pushing me to you
know get the fundamentals down so then I
can make like the walk OneTouch goals
and also just kind of pushing up the
wall so then you can actually make those
aerials which I still can't but there's
still really such great practice and
then reward factor involved with rockety
even when it comes down to like player
positioning like stuff that we take for
granted in sports and where you are like
anticipating with a ball
that's kind of a rocket leagues all
about yeah every match every second is
fun because if you're not going for the
ball you're kind of planning two steps
ahead or I'm going to say okay Mary's
about to push it over here and then I
think Danny's gonna hit it back here if
I'm right here I might get a goal I'm on
top of it being just like a genuinely
very fun game to keep back and playing
they've also been really good with TLC
both paid on free stuff as well there's
been three Dale sees some free some not
and they've all been really fun adding
hours to the game when you want to talk
about just more bang for your buck like
the game itself in its core is already
fun and now you're just adding different
modes to play that are really fun new
cars items Halloween items Christmas
items you name it there's always a
reason to come back I think they had an
ice hockey yesterday Mike just keeps on
coming we're so in love with content in
these modern games that we love big
games and big experience we play for
hours and hours I think it says
something to the quality of rocket
League that this is a game that really
gets distilled down that its entire
essence can be experienced in five
minutes and you know weeks and months
later we're still enjoying that five
minutes over and over again and that's
why I guess it's number two on our top
games of 2015